okay you said they were making things
yes in some kind of machines we didn't
ask what it's the clubs they murder
those goats with shut up
i agree with irving ond is the next
piece of this now once we've mapped the
whole floor to be clear i do not approve
of mapping
right
hey guys pete here today i'm going to be
talking about severance episode 6 which
was a game changer and i guess they all
have been if you really think about it
there's a deliberate dispersal of
reveals in this show that my mildewed
little brain really appreciates we
learned so many new things romantic
fraternization may be frowned upon but
the lumen manual doesn't say anything
about lip to lip contact i bring that up
here because this was such a fantastic
scene and i fear that it might get lost
in the shuffle while i'm discussing
everything else that happened after all
in hide and seek we met another audi
learned that there is something called
part-time innis and that love does not
transcend severance at least dylan
doesn't think so once again helly asked
the question we were all thinking is the
work they do important because it is or
because they say it is i'll be getting
into that question and everything else
that happened right after a quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
severance season 1 episode 6 yet then
this video won't be for you and with
that out of the way let's get into it
in my last video i mentioned how i was
starting to focus on the employees that
weren't severed and i have to say that
none of my speculating about them
included harmony having what i presume
is a recreation of the room she stayed
in as a child in her house if her
allegiances weren't clear this and the
shrine and the core principles up on the
wall the kool-aid has been drunk and
this isn't a recent event as a child she
attended the myrtle egan school for
girls which was founded in 1952 and we
got that information from this thing
which i don't know what else to call it
besides a shrine there are all kinds of
things that could turn out to be
important in here the one thing that
really jumped out to me was what looked
like a hospital bracelet with the name
charlotte cobell on it harmony was
probably born in the 60s or 70s which
means this could be her mother's the
birthday donut is 1944 so it's probably
not a sibling and in a weird coincidence
yesterday would have been her birthday
the other thing we learn in this scene
is that greener thinks that he's figured
out who cracked reintegration and we'll
come back to that neither one of these
things turns out to be the most exciting
thing that happens outside of the office
because we meet dylan's audi he looks
pretty normal he has a kid but we find
out that they can wake them up remotely
milchak arrives at his house in relation
to the ideographic card that he put in
his back pocket when he was in o and d
it turns out that this benign looking
thing is somehow sensitive information
so much so he asked dylan if someone
paid him to smuggle it out it turns out
that he didn't take it out of the office
at all he just hit it and is in he gives
that information up right away what's
really crazy here though is that he sees
his child a person his any knows nothing
about and you do have to wonder how this
will affect him when he wakes up the
next time miltek is upset that it
happened that the kid didn't listen to
him but i guess that's what he gets for
waking him up at home this is big there
are so many ways this could be misused
by lumen at first i was thinking that it
would almost be a deal breaker if they
knew this was possible that it would
have to be hidden away in the paperwork
they sign but then i'm not sure because
he did have to come to audi dylan at
home and explain to him what he was
about to do the audi's know milchik that
part isn't weird they have to coordinate
with him you saw mark call him to tell
him he was staying at home and heli
during her first day but the innies what
is dylan going to think about this when
he wakes up the next day at the office
things had been getting spicy there both
the innie and audi versions of mark are
starting to rebel this starts out with
him reading a passage from ricken's book
where he talks about camaraderie being
about standing together in hard times
recognizing a common struggle in another
person and reaching out to lend a loving
hand i mentioned how things were heating
up with irv and burt with their little
trip to the room that has a garden in it
for some reason their secret place and
irv is pushing for this idea of uniting
the departments like keir always wanted
kelly is pumped up about making a map
and i do believe there's some chemistry
going on between her and mark as they're
talking miss casey's name comes up and
this is when we hear about the idea of
part-time innies miss koble tells him
that they're not as socialized but they
still have to be held accountable and
miss casey is in the break room which
means she's severed this concept of
part-time innies i'm not a hundred
percent sure on after thinking about it
i think it means that maybe they just
call her in when they need her maybe
she's not always sitting around in that
office just waiting to get people
wellness sessions and that would mean
that she has a chip but it's only
activated when she comes in there's a
lot of talk about how weird she was when
they were in her office and this could
just be because she's not used to being
around people in that setting i've
talked a lot about their experiential
reality maybe that's attributed to her
just experiencing new things outside of
what she normally does when she's there
cobella is also concerned that they've
been running around looking into these
other departments while theirs is
falling woefully behind and this prompts
mark to ask what is it we actually do
here she says that we serve keir and
after she lays into him she tells him
that mdr needs to hit quota and that
their hallway privileges are revoked
this lights a fire under him temporarily
but he has a change of heart and decides
to defy the order he gets everyone
together and they head straight over to
ond it's funny because it seems like
this is the most people that any of them
have ever seen at the same time and even
funnier when they're asking each other
what they do and both departments
realize that they really don't know omd
is definitely 3d printing watering cans
but they don't know why and they had
previously been printing hatchets burt
says that there's a lot that's unknown
but they keep plugging along because
it's important work obviously and irving
backs him up saying that everything we
do here is important and i'm not sure
that they could have made this feel more
ridiculous than it does at this point
mark has his big moment when he says why
don't they tell us what we do here what
are they so afraid of if the eagan
philosophy is illumination above all
which irv quickly steps in to correct
him saying illumination beyond all then
why are they there working in the dark
it is a good question mark bert is on
board he decides that him and mark
should make contact with this goat
department and see what they know but
then just as dylan is grabbing that
laminated card milchik comes in and
breaks things up back at mdr cobell is
waiting she sings a song about keir
before greener comes in and takes mark
to the break room he does see miss casey
coming out on his way in and they have a
moment there that i suppose is probably
him feeling responsible for what she
just went through and then the next time
we see him is that night out to dinner
with alexa and he has marks on his hand
from that experience which i'm not sure
what to make out of that we hadn't seen
any physical abuse when we looked into
the break room in the past perhaps he
was punching a wall or something along
those lines i couldn't believe that
alexa would go out with him again but he
does handle it a lot better this time
his ex-wife comes up in their
conversation and in relation to not
being able to have kids he throws out
this idea that this is the life you were
given more or less you figure out what
to do with it which is odd coming from
someone who has had this procedure done
mark ends up seeing petey's daughter
june on a poster and they go and see her
play in her band it's a punk band they
have a song [ __ ] you lumini hates you
lumen is the chorus and mark sings along
he asks her how she's doing he mentions
how he thought petey would like the song
and it's awkward but i feel like they'll
probably see each other again if not
this scene would kind of feel
unnecessary
earlier when she was walking around
devon ran into the woman from the
birthing retreat who didn't remember her
even a little bit this seemed odd
because they just shared that experience
it's not that long ago and so later when
she's at home she looks into who gabby
is it turns out that the man she met her
with in the park is a state senator he's
a proponent of legalized severance in
the articles we see about him we notice
that lumen and other companies do it so
they're not the only company out there
that has severance and he took money in
campaign funding from them so that's
their person in the government at least
one of them that makes you wonder about
gabby because it did legitimately seem
like she had no memory of devin
whatsoever which could be explained if
she was severed if you go back and watch
the scene she is kind of vague about
things and when you first see it you
think maybe she's just uncomfortable
with this stranger but there's a chance
that this is some kind of an any
situation where she just doesn't really
know what's going on while she's doing
her research her lactation consultant
comes over and it turns out to be miss
cobell or miss selvig i guess in this
instance not sure how she got this
training where that came from but she
seems pretty great at it and she's great
with the baby so i'm sure there's more
to that story it's made to seem that
mark just brought it up and she ended up
over there but it seemed suspicious that
she would get involved with this i don't
know if she's looking for some kind of
leverage against him it's really hard to
say when she goes back home greener
comes over and tells her that he got a
tip about this name ragabi that we heard
at the beginning of the episode he seems
completely surprised with her wearing
the outfit that makes her look like a
nurse he does ask if she wants to come
with him to look for ragabi but she
doesn't and he tells her that
maintenance is at the office installing
something so alexa and mark had come
home while he's lying in bed awake we
see that he's thinking of petey's death
he decides to go out and retrieve the
phone which he threw in the trash can
earlier and it rings immediately and
this time he finally answers the voice
on the other end wants to meet and so
now he's heading to the college where
greyner just went we see both of them
arrive there but we only see him meet up
with this woman who doesn't identify
herself before the episode ends because
of the phone and the situation and the
fact that grainer has tracked the same
person down there's a distinct
possibility that mark's on his way to
becoming reintegrated but we're gonna
have to wait until the next episode to
find out what happens when greener shows
up and when they go back into the office
they have a new door it looks sort of
like an elevator door but i presume it's
just there to keep them inside you see
the maintenance guy open it with one of
those key cards and that's where we
leave things
so just a ton of interesting stuff here
the fact that the innies are in the dark
as much as we are as to what they do all
day at work continues to satisfy i go
back and forth on whether it's important
or not and when you consider scary
numbers baby goats 3d printed hatchets
and these cards that look like nothing
that have some real importance it's just
hard to say i haven't come up with a
good explanation of what these
idiographic instructions are supposed to
be conveying and i didn't see any great
ideas when i went looking online either
it might turn out to be important that
milcek was worried that he was able to
get them out through the elevator but i
really don't know there does seem to be
some pressure for them to do work this
idea of the quota has come up a couple
of times now and the addition of the
door to keep them inside their
department seems to reinforce this idea
of control seeing where cobell came from
makes me believe that this is all part
of the angle we knew there was this cult
of personality around kyr and this
corporate culture but it looks like it
goes a bit deeper from her perspective
this door seems like a good idea but it
could backfire the winds of rebellion
are sweeping through mdr with the
addition of halle them meeting o and d
kobel's cruel treatment of mark and the
introduction of rickens book all these
things are working together and i mean i
can't really imagine what a rebellion
would look like considering all they
have to do is throw them in the elevator
and they just turn into a different
person but i feel like we're headed in
that direction i'm excited to see what
mark finds out with this reintegration
thing but it kind of seems like there's
not enough time for that to actually
happen in this season i mean i could be
wrong but i'm not sure how you would
wrap that up illumination beyond all for
everyone except for the innies where are
they headed with this thing i think that
is a good place to leave things let me
know in the comments what you thought
about this episode how you're feeling
now that we're getting close to the end
what are your theories how are they
changing please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon